so you as the ancient philosopher
mathematician have concluded that in
order for the multiplication of positive
and negative numbers to be consistent
with everything that you've been
constructing so far all of the other
properties of multiplication that you
know so far that you need a negative
number
times a positive number or a positive
times a negative to give you a negative
number and a negative
times a negative
to give you a positive number and so you
accept it so it's all consistent but it
still does not make complete concrete
sense to you you want to con you want to
have a slightly deeper intuition than
just having to accept it so that it's
consistent with the distributive
property and whatever else and so you
try another thought experiment you say
well what is just basic multiplication
doing so if i say 2
times
if i say 2 times 3
one way to conceptualize this basic
multiplication here is really repeated
addition so you could view this as two
threes
so two threes would literally be three
plus three and notice there are two of
them there are two of these or you could
view this as three twos and so this is
the same thing as two plus 2 plus 2 and
there are
and there are three of them and either
way you conceptualize them you get the
same exact answer this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to 6. fair
enough you knew that before you even
tried to tackle negative numbers and now
let's try to make one of these negatives
and see what one of these negative and
see what happens
let's do two
two times
negative three and i'm going to make the
negative in a different color 2 times
negative
2 times negative 3. well one way you
could view this is just the same analogy
here it's negative 3 twice so it would
be it would be negative three and i'll
try to color code it
negative three and then
another
negative
another negative three or you could say
negative three minus three or and now
this is the interesting thing instead of
over here since you said 2 times
positive 3 you added 2
3 times but since here it's 2 times
negative 3 you could also imagine that
you're going to subtract 2 3 times so
instead of and up here i could have
literally written plus 2 plus 2 plus 2
because this is a positive 3 right over
here all of a sudden since we're dealing
with a negative 3 we can imagine that
this is subtracting 2 3 times so this
would be
subtracting two
mind another subtract another two right
over here
subtract another two and then you
subtract another two another two right
over there let me color code it make
sure i don't get the colors messed up
and you have another two right over
there and noticed you did it once again
you did it three times
you did it three times so this was a
negative three essentially you are
subtracting two three times and either
way you conceptualize it right over here
you are going to get negative 6.
you're going to get negative 6 as the
answer
now so you're already starting to feel
good about this part right over here
negative times a positive a negative
times a positive or a positive times a
negative give you a negative now let's
take to the really unintuitive one a
negative times a negative all of a
sudden the negatives kind of cancel out
and give you a positive why is that the
case well we could just build from this
example right over here
let's say that we had let's say that we
had negative 2
let's say that we had negative 2
let me do it in a different color
i already used that color
negative 2
times
times negative 3
times negative 3.
so now we can do the coupling actually
i'll do this one first we're still
multiplying
something by negative 3. so we're going
to repeatedly subtract that thing three
times whatever that thing is but now
that thing isn't a positive two that
thing that we're going to subtract three
times is a negative two so let me make
it clear this says we're going to
subtract something three times we're
going to subtract something three times
so subtracting something subtracting
something subtracting something three
times that's what this part right over
here tells us and we're gonna do this
we're gonna do it exactly three times
over here was a positive two that we
subtracted 3 times now we're going to do
a negative 2.
now we're going to do a negative 2.
and we know from subtracting negative
numbers we've already built this
intuition that subtracting a negative is
the same thing it's like taking it's
like taking away someone's debt it's
like it's the same thing as adding a
positive and so this is going to be the
same thing as 2 plus 2 plus 2 which will
once again give you
once again give you positive 6. you can
use the same logic over here now instead
of adding negative 3 twice and really i
could have written this as i could have
written this as negative 3 up in this
example negative 3
let me write it this way negative
negative 3 and we added it
we added it and i'll write a plus out
here to make it clear over here we added
it twice we added negative 3 two times
over here since we now have a negative 2
we're going to subtract negative 3 twice
so we're going to subtract something
and we're going to subtract something
again and that something is going to be
our negative 3.
it's going to be our negative 3. so
negative negative and put our 3 right
over here and once again subtracting a
negative it's like taking away someone's
debt which is essentially giving them
money you're going this is the same
thing as adding 3 plus 3 which is once
again 6. so now you as the ancient
philosopher feel pretty good not only
does this
all consistent with all of the
mathematics you know the distributive
property the associative property
multiplying something times here all of
these things that you already know it
now actually makes conceptual sense to
you that this actually is very
consistent with your notion your
original notion or one of the possible
notions of multiplication which is as
repeated addition